[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hevy angel oh it's heavy
[Music]
what are you doing over there what do
you think I forget that from
belly flop
pretty fun
[Music]
you're so cute with your little camera
there's a little camera woman
I like your look you look like you're
from a steampunk movie James Brown
[Music]
all right we are now in our next hotel
we're back in Reykjavik this is the
other place that we're staying
yeah look at your cute little bed I love
how you get like your own little tiny
bed yeah for your switch is our bed it's
very interesting that everywhere we go
for a double they just put two twins
together I haven't seen like a
queen-size this is our view there's a
gas station right in front a subway and
then this whole thing is like a big road
so it's not very inviting to go out and
explore you can see the ocean way over
there there's the ocean so what do you
think of Iceland so far I like it really
it's been your favorite place even
though it's super cold allowing you to
wear three jackets to pants I can't wait
for the Blue Lagoon
I know me too I can't wait for that
that's gonna be so relaxing
[Music]
you're busting out your British accent
because they have the British flag what
are you gonna top what are you gonna
like and he tried to really love the
view right ice cream or dry bread ice
cream right here oh you got some meat
soup baby would you get this is
fermented shark
[Music]
[Applause]
or something it does smell like happy
years
results intent oh my goodness how order
a shot of Brenda never mind this is like
I know looks like my tuna cake but yeah
this is all like fish and stuff looks
like my tuna cakes look fancier how's
your soup alright so I think what I'm
working with is dried fish
[Music]
but my dad said it smelled like
cigarettes and it does we're gonna do
mirmix chart and I ordered a shot of
Brendan some of the people like I've
seen on YouTube bad but I can't say I
enjoyed that much this fermented shark
yeah Michelle Musa is a nice kind of
spoiled yeah
you like it you enjoy it I mean it's one
thing to say you can stomach it it's
another thing to say you actually enjoy
it yeah I like that flavor are you next
I can't even cut it okay I've tried my
hardest to cut this in half like a
journalist I say it paint my like green
strand that would not cut uh burn
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a really intended a recipe I burned
my tongue earlier on coffee so that
whole area that burnt it feels really
weird
I can't even look it's healing it it's
healing it it's so fermented it's
killing here hey you don't know what
drink the do for a break yeah the kamon
eh I'm finished it's like straight
pungent chemical flavor are you gonna
taste the fermented shark
oh you're brave did now you're gonna
know got your chaser I need to get my
you're gonna taste it with the meat soup
that's a week high five give me good
night
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it tastes like pee right like do you
like it what kind of people she
disapproves so when people and people
have to go through starvation they have
my ways to preserve food and is the way
to video and then how to do it respect
I don't like it maybe there's something
in it where four men like it and women
don't like it and like T yeah that's a
about you guys golden duck
so apparently the tour that we took and
two tours put in one so there was a
two-day tour and then a three-day tour
we finished a two-day tour yesterday and
then today starts the three-day tour I
don't even know we're doing today I'm
just going with the flow we'll see what
we get into
[Music]
you're wearing the sleeping bag I bought
for you yes finally came in handy if I
didn't bring it on this trip it's like I
will never use it true right there
[Music]
[Music]
to where we are now boss boss boss
I don't know gorgeous
[Music]
there's no warning for that it's just it
goes that's pretty cool a warning like a
rumble maybe is a rumble Rumble Rumble
and then it explodes no just explode I
[Music]
missed it dang it you're too busy
looking okay okay I kept trying to push
the button it wouldn't go
[Laughter]
I just want to get in there it's like a
nice warm jacuzzi
smells like sulfur whoa you get it
perfect timing
did you get it yeah my finger in the way
no it was pointing at it
[Music]
see the rainbow you want to go behind
the waterfall
yeah you do but go you're not going no I
don't want to get wet oh no way
it's not a good mixture
[Music]
[Music]
that was also on Game of Thrones
we do like it gave it their own story
like all these months starting from
Croatia even though we didn't go to a
drover big but we just got to go there
it's faint
they also filmed their Isaac you wanna
go swimming we're at the beach I feel
like I'm over it it's cold enemies take
a party
Isaac's headed enough with going on
these excursions he's tired he's cold
and plus we're also wet now because of
thanks to the waterfall so that was
under estimation of how wet we were
gonna be so it's made that when extra
cold now because we're wet my legs are
cold so my jeans are soaking wet so it
gets more miserable with every excursion
we go through
[Music]
[Music]
it's to walk up to the shore line then
all of a sudden there's a wave and it
sweeps you away Gary you know it's more
scary kid are you nice and warm
huh are you cold
yes you're warm and yes you're cold
your whole mouth area is it's getting
all wet here the light but you can't
look like Rorschach you're just not
having a very good time
[Music]
okay we're gonna discover it but we came
across it whoa a wave just hit this
recently it's all wet it's dripping
[Music]
all right a new hotel it sounds a lot
more spacious are you doing
[Music]
this hotel is different because
everyone's rooms is disconnected they
all have these little huts but we're in
this bigger building you're sad I don't
want you to get the combination I know a
little Hut those are cute but in order
for us to go get breakfast we need to go
down that pathway and go all the way to
that building so it's a bit of a walk in
the freezing cold but hey it's all part
of the experience did they actually oh
no I was about to say do they actually
have a big bed but it's still two beds
connected whoo this bathrooms nice cute
little sinks
I love how in Europe all the things are
so small I like that
[Music]
that was intense it was windy like crazy
and it was raining like crazy
everyone's coats are all addressed but
it
[Music]
we're getting ready to go okay actually
we are ready to go we're just going
[Music]
[Music]
sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's knocked out I want stinging me
Oh
because knocked out that's it might need
us about the camera you're gonna break
the camera under the feeling champion
champion undefeated champion is what I
said I can be your belt I'll be right
here yeah like a nice one great it's
been fun it's been extremely cold wall
the beds are separating your head is
under the bed what the heck that looks
crazy like [ __ ] being possessed
try it what is this his foot his hands
you try they don't what your feet I just
like your missus
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh is the first time we're actually
filming one of our tickle fights cuz
you've had a million we've never
captured any for a memory move me offer
you today yeah five like I was trying to
do you a night
Isaac's growing up oh nice
you're so strong now is a good job
you're sweating it's not [ __ ] people
sweat no sweat
wow you're superhuman cuz even I'm
sweating it guys we lost Isaac just go
around man
you failures you failed me okay yeah a
little weird oh oh
alright we're calling it a night see you
tomorrow
besides our well we got ice pick
that's pretty cool huh baby yeah what
are we gonna do we're gonna climb some
glacier we're gonna go on a glacier walk
hike fine climb yeah make it more
serious okay it's more serious
[Music]
yeah we're just can't recognize you guys
underneath all that
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
this is so Joe I know it's like we're
miserable but we're so happy moving
about this experience really really yeah
you don't think it's worth it yeah you
know look at this view
look at this we're not a planet for
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright alright so there's sulfur in the
water you're told and you're supposed to
keep the conditioner in your hair we
didn't do that sounds crazy underwater
does I chickened out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]